how do you guys feel about seasonal
products here in japan
because you know every country in the
world has like
seasonal products and stuff but i feel
like i can show you
here it's just heavily advertised but
like japan take it to the next level
whereas
half the shelf sometimes i feel is like
seasonal products yeah
every everything is seasonal everything
is a premium as well
i mean i i get it now i meant i remember
they would talk about it in the animes
they were like the enemies they're like
you don't know the pain until your
favorite item has been removed from the
combini yeah
and i feel that because i saw that as
well so many items that i just liked
for some reason the the what the items
that i specifically like would just
randomly get removed
yeah from the company yeah yeah i'd be
like i'll be like oh it'll be back next
week
not gonna lie every time i walk into a
corn beanie and i see something is like
new yeah i'm just like oh
i might grab one of those yeah i don't
know because like i
i don't want to try it i want to get
attached yeah that's exactly that's
exactly how i'm
feeling now trade i've been like so many
times living in japan i go to a company
i try out this new like oh this like new
product that's only available for spring
because it's like the spring special
winter special products try it
absolutely love it and then
a few months later it just disappears
i'm like [ __ ] man i want it now
you've given me a craving and you've
removed the craving and now i'm gonna
have to wait
all year for it to maybe come back yeah
for it to maybe come back because it
might not even come back i hate that
when they like bring out like a new
strong zero flavor
yeah i'm just like man this is way
better than the standard flavors too bad
it's only around for
two weeks and i'll never see it again
once it's gone yeah because it's not
just like items sometimes there's like
menu items on
on in like restaurants yeah only
available during certain seasons
i mean i feel the biggest problem with
that is that the one thing in japanese
like especially supermarkets and
restaurants
they love to do that whole like seasonal
premium [ __ ] is
with fruits oh god right we've gone out
we've ranted about fruits
about but like i remember like i went to
uh
i don't remember no i was a royal host i
went to a royal host
and they were doing this like seasonal
thing with grapes right
like the green grapes like the muskets
yeah and
i tried a few of them because i like
green grapes and i was like oh this is
really nice
went back the next week and it was gone
i'm like [ __ ] hell this is really
premium isn't it it's like
i swear it was only on the menu for like
three days and it's just gone
yeah it's where they they take like
limited time sales to like another level
here because
it feels like a lot of things are just
very limited
it's it's a limited edition something
it's limited edition products i mean
you know one can argue that that's like
very good marketing it is very good
people will look at something premium
being like well i guess if i can only
get it now i should get it now it is it
is
kind of cool going into a place and just
having stuff be new constantly but then
there is also that fact like yeah i did
really like this one thing and you took
it away from me yeah so i'm very
it's like the same thing whenever you
travel to a new like prefecture or
something and there's
every brief like we talked about before
every prefecture has a specialty and an
item you can only get in that prefecture
every prefecture will tell you that this
is the best rice
yeah in japan so every prefecture will
tell you it's all [ __ ] up so like
definitely living in japan i've tried
more like i've gone out of my comfort
zone with trying
new products and new suites and new
views and everything but at the same
time
i've just found more cravings that i
can't get on a
normal basis anymore because it's only
available in from a certain prefecture
what was the [ __ ] maple cakes
that we bought from yeah the manju that
we bought from like hiroshima oh
yeah those were so [ __ ] good but the
problem is you can only buy them in
[ __ ] hiroshima so it's just like cool
i'm not really a sweet person but then i
like yeah we bought those and i ate one
and i
sometimes you go you go you try out this
new thing you're like it's it's all
right it's it's mid it's whatever right
but sometimes you find that really
amazing product and you're like [ __ ]
but then but then on the contrary isn't
it amazing when you find that one
regional thing that you think you're
never going to see in tokyo and then
just
one random shop sells it yeah man [ __ ]
yeah like i remember like uh
in tochigi for example yeah they have
this thing called lemon milk
yeah which i [ __ ] love and it's like
a it was a regional specific thing for
the longest time and i was like
well [ __ ] i gotta make a trip up to
tortugi every time i want this yeah so i
would always buy it in bulk when i would
come back home
but of course it doesn't last right and
then the craving comes back and i get
[ __ ] progressions
but then i remember uh i walked into
like a random company once and they were
just selling it
right and it was like [ __ ] it was
like [ __ ] el dorado you know i was
like
[ __ ] bought all that [ __ ] and brought
it back and i was like all right no
put it on google maps this is the
company that sells the lemon milk
man the the sapporo special
um thingy beer what is it what's it
called again sapporo beer
no no no no no it's uh what's the
prefecture called hokkaido
yeah yeah we forgot for a second there
yeah hokkaido the sapporo beard is way
better
when they have like the the sapporo
actual sapporo
yeah yeah yeah it's like so good i want
to bring so much back but it's heavy
does it actually make a difference i
genuinely think it tastes really better
yeah it's weird
i think sapporo in japan tastes
worse than i remember it tasting abroad
i don't know it's it's it's weird
maybe it's cause i have it way more
often now but when i had sapporo like
on tap somewhere else i was like oh this
is so much better than the beer
that we that the other yeah yeah but i
think it's because you're comparing it
to other beers right like i remember
asaki tasting
infinitely better in australia yeah now
it tastes [ __ ] i don't know why
but now i'm more scared to go back to
australia and have the [ __ ] beer in
australia i'm like
if i think a sake is mid now which used
to be like god tier before
yeah i don't want to drink a vb right
like i feel like i'm gonna throw up
drinking that [ __ ] because i can't
imagine going back and going like
drinking a
calling again oh god so they'll cuddling
is like
piss water in the uk yeah yeah one of
the worst beers and there'll be sports
bars in japan that are like
we're partnered with carly
we sell carling and carlsberg i've seen
that before because uh
budweiser yeah budweiser yeah because
i've seen like
uh special special restaurants they sell
like this thai beer called singer beer
and it's like in in thailand it's like
the dirtiest cheapest beer you can get
like they don't even put it on tap they
put it in like they put in like a can
i don't know the tiniest of the yeah
yeah yeah i didn't
in japan they on a menu like 500 500 yen
for a little can of singapore yeah what
you're what you're wearing from thailand
yeah it's like who is going to go to
japan
and be like oh we have exclusive
heineken
in bottle 700 yen please it's like what
no yo yo heineken in amsterdam it's
[ __ ] great
name is good beer or wherever it's brood
is the best well yeah
like you know i had a [ __ ] uh uh oh
my god i'm
blanking here the irish one um
yeah it's like get us on and just hit
different yeah it's [ __ ] amazing but
then i had a guinness here on top
because they were having it on top so
i'm like i was curious i was like all
right well get us in ireland is so good
i do that every time as well yeah i was
like oh they have guinness on tap here
in japan let me see why did you do it
just to get hurt because
because because you hold out the hope
right yeah you hold out the hope
maybe this is the one yeah maybe this is
the place it's like
it's like this pub might be the ssr pool
yeah right
exactly it's like this might be the one
maybe this is the one and every time i
get disappointed
never gonna be the one i was like every
time i see like irish pub in tokyo i was
like
yeah is that the one is that the one
place that i can go
it's cause it's not even in tokyo it's
worldwide for me and like every time i
see a guinness on top because that's
never that can [ __ ] oh no no but like it
has to be on tap because i'm like it's
on tap
maybe maybe this is the one maybe maybe
they've figured out the secret and uh
i'm still waiting if if anyone in the
world has ever tasted the guinness
outside of ireland that tastes as good
as in ireland they're delusional
please please hit me up i need to know
and i will literally travel to that
[ __ ] place
why not just travel to ireland oh yeah
i'll just go to ireland at that point no
i'm i'm curious i'm curious to see if
there's any place outside it doesn't
travel well you know that's the sad
truth of it gone it's like kangaroo
as well like that [ __ ] does not travel
i'm okay i'm okay with that staying in
australia actually
i i had a kangaroo steak here in japan
at an outback steakhouse of all [ __ ]
places
just because i was curious and i was
like man this [ __ ] does not travel i i
found that out on that day
that kangaroo does not travel you know
what's also bizarre uh when i was in
uh hokkaido i was at a train station and
it was like 11 a.m
yeah there's so many people drinking
beer in the station
yeah yeah like just like everyone
everyone every kind of like
you know uh group you can imagine like
young girls old men
young men they were all just chilling in
the station just drinking a sapporo beer
yeah i'm like
i'm like this is weird it's just water
everyone's just drinking beer at like
11am what the [ __ ]
yeah it's in the train station like yeah
they're like public waiting areas it's
just so big it's like that in okinawa as
well but instead of
beer it's awamori which is essentially
just really
[ __ ] strong it's basically okinawan
vodka that's the only way to describe it
because i i forget sometimes about the
public drinking lawsuit
which you can drink publicly publicly
here because i feel like
i didn't expect to see so many people
drinking in the daytime in japan
like i i get surprised when i see an is
like izakaya open because i'm like who
the [ __ ] is going to an izakaya like 12
a.m
oh you'll see them and they'll be
drinking a bevy yeah yeah exactly i
never i never thought that the the
concept of like
lunchtime beer was a thing here until i
saw it for myself
yeah i was like wow they're actually
having lunch it's it's like you it's for
people you don't expect because it's
always like the old people
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah people were
just like hey let's just have a lunch
time crack open a beer
like four p.m too far in the uk that's
all the old people do as well yeah
if you ever go to weatherspoons at like
midday you'll always see the same old
people
downing pints yeah like 12 and you're
like it's okay they'll be asleep by four
anyway so yeah
doesn't matter